i think elsewhere he said that putin
was not a good kgb agent that's right a
mediocre one but
is an excellent politician yep
and a good organizer he was known as a
really really good organizer when when
yeltsin hired him as a
prime minister
he
he cleaned up the mess to because he
yeltsin
was it was
under yeltsin
russia deteriorated tremendously and it
became sort of a
mix of an oligarchy and a criminal
enterprise and
chaotic
so he had skills that made him a good
executive absolutely now let's go back
to him as a kgb agent he was a kgb agent
i mean
uh you know according to him once a kgb
agent always a kgb agent but
16 years let's say something like this
uh what do you think about
from your experience
um now you're
maybe uh the same age as him
approximately the same age as him he's a
little younger a little younger
what
do you think about the kgb experience he
had
made him the man he is what aspect of
that
from your own experience well how much
that does that define you who you are
how you think about the world how you
analyze uh the geopolitics of the world
how you analyze human nature now i got
to tell you one thing he had a different
type of training than i did mine was
one-on-one
and he
went
to school so to speak so
classroom journey right
uh
so um but but uh fundamentally he he was
not
a top
agent and this is very simple to there's
only one one thing you need to know he
he knows german pretty well
so he where was he deployed
in east germany
not in west germany not in switzerland
not in austria that's where they sent
the best right one would think
generally
we're learning here right so this is
your classification of where they send
the best you know there's people
classify all kinds of stuff like uh what
is the best university in the world what
is the best football team in the world
you start to get a sense the good guys
get sent the the best athletes get sent
to
uh well we can disagree on this but the
football team is
but you have a sense and you're saying
that the best agents would have been
sent one would think so now that this is
not for enforcing argument but uh
i
also have it from from a word from the
horse's mouth
uh
which horse
only or what kind of horse what was the
breeze oh like collugan uh you you know
who oleg kalugin is and he's still he's
still alive he was at one point uh the
head of counterintelligence for the
first directorate espionage right
and putin was in the first directorate
and reported to logan for a while
and oleg told me to my face
that oleg was not an impressive
agent trainee or agent that vladimir
putin was not impressive not impressive
at all now he's biased
given his current situation
and well yeah you know he could still
make it up because he had this big
ruckus when when he was in parliament
and called called putin the war criminal
about the
war in serbia uh not only could he make
it up i wouldn't trust his analysis
i mean i have to you know what when
people
i've been working very hard even before
this war to try to understand objective
analysis of
all the parties involved you have to
really keep an open mind here to see
clearly to understand
if you are to try to
help in some way
make a better world
uh in this case stop this war yeah or
have
all the countries involved flourish
bring out the best the people remove the
corruption and the greed and the
destructive aspects of the governments
and let the people flourish for all that
you have to put all the biases aside
all the political bickering all the
um
i don't know
all the biased analysis
and there's
there's a lot of propaganda
that says that in fact
putin was it was a good agent
how else would he rise to the ranks
right because he
he was a good politician and he had made
a lot of good connections and
with within the kgb
allow me to say something here you just
uh you just taught me a lesson
and and and the lesson
i i should have figured out myself
because i i keep on telling people that
in the intelligence world you never know
the truth 100
so when you said all i could make that
up of course he could have
but you get to a point where
you're forced to make a decision or have
an opinion and then you use your best
educated guess yes so i'm i'm going to
take the certainty of the statement that
i made back yes because you it's quite
possible that you're right well what
i've noticed about vladimir putin and
this is true about for example donald
trump and all those kinds of
um divisive figures
that some for some reason people's
opinion on the details of those people
are very sticky once you decide this is
a bad guy yeah
there's like a black hole and people are
not able to think like one act at a time
you don't have to
like that doesn't somehow justify this
that somehow doesn't uh
remove all the evil things that are done
but you can analyze clearly each of the
actions and to me it is interesting to
see how did this man
rise through the ranks
now you're saying that
to be a kgb agent there's a lot of
skills involved
and perhaps
raw
um
technical
skill of
spycraft is perhaps not related to the
skill of raising rising through the
ranks right
and you're saying is a politician he was
good at right lying and influencing uh
that is something that that is
significant as a significant uh talent
uh and ability that an agent must have
that helps you
as a politician
you